barn door digital suppose ok grunick day
is killer
we have until 8:30 to get this shot it
is currently 819 that's a really tight
fit me and Helen are we are you from
finishing her I am free zip ties and a
proper installation and we're here to go
you nice
it's coming along pretty smoothly
actually
like I've been a camera
so this is it
what do you mean oh I gotta gain it I
have it actually because sometimes they
don't live long enough if I were to have
one for a long time I think I'd give my
name
I mean I need to spend a little bit of
time to come up with a good name they
need to be heard yeah maybe after the
first flight oh I'll land it I'll be
like this name are you ready I think so
okay so got my batteries got a finished
versa copter from flight test I hope I
don't crash it I might crash it I will
probably crash it I'm not going to crash
it this is honestly one of the more
stressful things this week that to deal
with tomorrow including nine pages of
dialogue today after shooting nine more
pages of dialogue but now we're getting
into the end of the day it's really
Pleasant outside and we're going to just
bust a couple of nice easygoing dialogue
scenes throughout the day up salmon's
now stepped in for his episode and then
I will be doing mine afterwards and I
probably will have one set up I'll have
time to do one set up now I'm out of my
seat I'll have time to do one go be out
here by 7:30 otherwise it'd go into
overtime
there's also like Union rules about like
like Sixers no cheese these new for
today oh my god there's also a union
rules about the next day like say let's
say the window over time let's say we
shot until midnight I think it's ten
hour turnaround you can't have the crew
back on set until ten hours an end of
call tonight is that what it is - no I
can't member also if you do night shoots
and you go back to day shoots I think
it's a fifty six hour turnaround it's at
fifty six dollars between your night
shoots and your day she really a little
there's a help make everyone like it
back to health being safe schedule yeah
also it's for safety the entire people
on set carrying heavy equipment around
easy to get hurt all right yeah I see me
oh I am the camera
oh [ __ ] the quad is finally built and
I'm about to do the actual maiden flight
for the very first time on this thing
and I'm beyond excited but I'm also
quite nervous because I might crash this
so I'm distracted by all the cool stuff
happening in the air you guys are
joining engines all right this is
rolling history so I'm not rolling a
GoPro so what you're seeing is literally
just what's being recorded by these
goggles hey I'm going to do something to
fly it out there and I'm going to put
the headset on I'm going to start off
flying just level mode so that it will
auto correct so it knows which way is
down which ways up and then once I get a
little bit more comfortable that I'm
going to slip it into full acro mode so
the cypress floor it'll just keep going
forward until it's upside down okay I'm
going to flip an AK remote all right I
am in accra mode now so I'll be home as
it goes you're afraid
all right let's try flip I've been
applying a crow for a total of like 20
seconds you okay going use a little road
I did it I did it I didn't barrel so
much easier to fly anything with it oh
my god I'm having so much fun I'm gonna
try powerless ready oh you'd put there
so easy easy
oh let's go out of the sky
you don't know where you're at it may
have a battery you know it all roughly
where you were I think I was out there
Oh out there yeah I was born along and
I'll set the front dip and I couldn't
control it
let's go look for it can I can I run out
there okay we're gonna pick our angle
and then yeah I'm always working out
today we're moving look back anything
will work best from the night
I think this fish know that no like this
that are honestly we're going to hear a
really nice background I'm a little
worried that like about it it's dark
when we start to shoot because it's not
gonna be anything there so when you
think we can do this before get far yeah
if we take a background we totally could
do it before get some come on a which
background was better on your camera I
agree
are we still taking the background what
do you like wait commits of it being
dark and then turn the light on
it is prettier I'd rumiko and I think it
is better the one so much alike
Nora and Tom yeah and insert a tube I
like your idea of long lens that cool
last I checked
didn't you have only two setups or
something one oh my god
all right I'm also shooting we can flip
it up I think we can get this provide
protein yes get this baby boy oh just
get out of here you for real then hold
off on them oh I'm just trying to be
realistic all the fighting game the
whole gang on the couch a little bit of
this would be nice to buy the first tape
they could maybe just get the insert
while they're honing in on the perform
now let's do this uh not to kill you
it's like since sundown and we do want
to get as much as we can if we do our
wives first we punch in and bring it out
and that way as an adviser close as they
drink posted I need you to knock in any
direction and find out why because I'm
just a diver I'm used to people we beat
the shut up and that as I saw that
hear droning droning droning hear Donnie
Donnie Rooney did the field is huge man
oh my god
grass is really long which makes me
think that going to be hard to spot some
a distance yeah I'm just looking for
anything that doesn't look like a
natural form in this grass sound uh send
an army man here poor guy the chute
didn't open
no luck
let's do it I don't remember very well
where it was it happened so fast
yes I only get one set up that's it I
got two then I like the idea of being
back there with the you know just to the
compressed space background life cocaine
beautiful huh Alex why are you acting
ahead of working on your YouTube channel
um oops that's a secret
you promised you wouldn't talk about it
yeah well I [ __ ] that one up just to
just tomorrow
yeah so if that light is problematic I
would actually consider like maybe
sweeping to your right a little bit more
yeah yeah any set ready and action
okay I mean bad right to the wire so I
shoot every day every minute news you
like do doing great
ready and action yes got the car going
on guys
we are very short on time we have until
8:30 to get this shot and it's currently
819 you could go to 8:30 we have to deal
with our penalty for time tomorrow as
well as the fact that we go into
overtime the cops production a lot of
money that's on us
we go we got to go man we're running out
of this taping over time integration gun
ready and action
cut yeah nice work huh let's love the
guys yeah oh great yeah we're done
sister up well for today yeah tell us a
little bit about yourself
I'm Alex's hobby I run the channel of
hobby production I'll make a video for
11 years acting is a big difference
mostly because when we shoot something I
want to go look at it right away I want
to go look and like watch what I just
did so I can fix it or do better but
instead I have somebody behind the
screen telling me what's effective and
so it's cool to like usually I'm making
my own vision come to life so it's cool
to help me help make their vision come
to life and I think I got that but
acting bug I love it I'm going to make
youtube videos but am i acting over -
we've got good instincts like I've
noticed that your feeling you're dead
time when you're not talking with
interesting stuff and when you are
performing you're making a point of not
only trying to make them own authentic
but you're trying to come up with ways
that are interesting that make other
people around you laugh and watch you
know I'm glad you noticed like you
talked about like going out to watch if
you do on the camera like I'm also used
like when you get a shot just like okay
let me see it again
yeah it worked out towards this reunion
shoot there currently that playing back
the footage she gives a union position
really yeah and we didn't hire for it I
can't actually new playback Oh
what's weird man we didn't shoot strange
bug but whatever they are having man to
be so cool this stuff one Oh
battery's been out I guess it's an
interview okay okay use my flight
there's
- black where okay okay okay yet not
straight
okay so here's like that main like
cousin walkway that goes up in center so
you're more towards the right no I'm
literally heading for the street okay so
somewhere near that tree cool all right
okay I think I think we can find it now
I think we can do it little X on the a
lot of things that want to hit each
other that is where the feel when that
happens maybe that day I have to wait
till all the planes kill each other well
it's going watch it enjoy yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we got a moment and then we'll be able
to go out there and retrieve it
we're waiting for these guys LAN or
George private lot of people right we
think we know where it is pretty sure
pretty sure
where is Ren's little quad I think after
this that deserves the name so there's
over basement somewhere right here yes
in this clearing
there's someone into the tree for sure
now look
I hear something I hear I'll hear it
it's beeping yeah beeping its living
there is you know baby bird
Hey well that work yeah I had a great
flight until it I don't know why I fell
out of the sky
this came undone I wonder if it got
nicked yeah it'll do it actually yeah
really you had a nice coordinated turn
ago yeah it's going to fall it flip for
no reason you know you get a very nice
coordinated turn what's the name ran I
don't have a good name but I'm going to
call this the flying chili pepper chili
bird oh we got out of him I was like oh
I'm going with it well ring had a good
flight I'm satisfied you would apply
immediately pepper flew greatest
hardware sitting on your desk for how
long and it flew yeah amazing so I want
to get a big thank you to our friends
over at flight test they've taken us
into the family and I love it flight
path 2018 one anything else you guys
let's go you need coats and hopefully
south oh man
well P we got lots of invested when I
learn or help you game I think you're
sharing this world outgrown the hobby so
if you guys are interested in RC plans
make sure you check out blank test you
find us in here
Oh corridor digital came through them
they are killers